WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS THIS
HOUR.
IN FACT, WE'RE BREAKING IT FOR
YOU RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT THAT
TEXT MESSAGE THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S THEN CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS, ONE THAT
OUTLINED A WAY TO DELIVER THE
ELECTION TO TRUMP BEFORE THE
VOTES HAD EVEN FINISHED BEING
COUNTED.
THREE SOURCES TELL ME AND MY
COLLEAGUE JAMIE GANGEL THAT
MEMBERS OF THE BIPARTISAN HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION
BELIEVE THAT FORMER ENERGY
SECRETARY AND TEXAS GOVERNOR
REPUBLICAN RICK PERRY TEXTED
MARK MEADOWS NOVEMBER 4th.
THAT'S THE DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
NOW MULTIPLE SOURCES WHO HAVE
PERRY'S PHONE NUMBER AND
SEPARATELY DATABASES OF PHONE
NUMBERS CONFIRM THAT THE NUMBER
FROM WHICH THAT TEXT WAS SENT,
WHICH CNN OBTAINED FROM A
SOURCE, THAT NUMBER BELONGS TO
RICK PERRY.
THAT UNSETTLING TEXT MESSAGE
SENT WHILE VOTES WERE STILL
BEING COUNTED IN SEVERAL STATES.
IT SAID, QUOTE, HERE'S AN
AGGRESSIVE STRATEGY.
WHY CAN'T GEORGIA, NORTH
CAROLINA, PENNSYLVANIA AND OTHER
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED STATE
HOUSES DECLARE THIS IS BS, WHERE
CONFLICTS IN ELECTION NOT CALLED
THAT NIGHT AND JUST SEND THEIR
OWN ELECTORS TO VOTE AND HAVE IT
GO TO SCOTUS, THE SUPREME COURT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
NOW A SPOKESMAN FOR RICK PERRY
TELLS US THE FORMER GOVERNOR
DENIES HAVING SENT THAT TEXT.
WHEN ASKED HOW HE EXPLAINED THE
FACT THAT THE TEXT CAME FROM
RICK PERRY'S PHONE NUMBER, WHICH
WE CONFIRMED THROUGH MULTIPLE
WAYS, THE SPOKESMAN HAD NO
EXPLANATION.
THE TEXT MESSAGE WAS AMONG MORE
THAN 6,000 DOCUMENTS THAT MARK
MEADOWS TURNED OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE.
IT WAS MADE PUBLIC ON TUESDAY
WHEN DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN AND
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE MEMBER
JAMIE RASKIN OF MARYLAND READ
THE TEXT ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
DURING DEBATE ON WHETHER TO HOLD
MARK MEADOWS IN CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
RASKIN CITED THE TEXT AS
EVIDENCE DEMONSTRATING WHY THE
COMMITTEE NEEDED TO INTERVIEW
MEADOWS ABOUT THE EVENTS LEADING
UP TO AND ON JANUARY 6th.
>> HOW DID THIS TEXT INFLUENCE
THE PLANNING OF MARK MEADOWS AND
DONALD TRUMP TO TRY TO DESTROY
THE LAWFUL ELECTORAL COLLEGE
MAJORITY THAT HAD BEEN
ESTABLISHED BY THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE STATES FOR
JOE BIDEN?
>> WE SHOULD NOTE RASKIN
MISTAKENLY SAID ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR THAT IT WAS A HOUSE
LAWMAKER WHO SENT THE TEXT.
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IT WAS.
THEY BELIEVE IT WAS RICK PERRY,
THE COMMITTEE.
AFTER CNN REACHED OUT FOR
COMMENT, A SOURCE CLOSE TO
RASKIN TOLD US THE CONGRESSMAN
CONFIRMED HE HAD ACTUALLY MADE A
MISTAKE AND HE HAS NOW WRITTEN A
LETTER TO CORRECT THE
CONGRESSIONAL RECORD.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THIS WITH
CNN'S SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT
JAMIE GANGEL.
MY PARTNER IN THIS STORY AS
ALWAYS.
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS TEXT WHICH
WAS SENT THE DAY AFTER ELECTION
DAY, BEFORE MANY STATES HAD EVEN
CALLED WHO WON.
>> MY UNDERSTANDING IS THIS
IS -- LOOK, THERE ARE A LOT OF
IMPORTANT TEXTS THE COMMITTEE
HAS.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ONE
BECAUSE IT IS NOVEMBER 4th.
AND AGGRESSIVE, TO USE THE WORD
IN THE TEXT, TO SAY THE LEAST.
IMAGINE THE ELECTION HAS NOT
BEEN CALLED.
THE VOTES HAVE NOT BEEN COUNTED.
AND THIS TEXT MESSAGE COMES TO
MARK MEADOWS BASICALLY LAYING
THE GROUNDWORK TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE HOW THIS
COMES FROM RICK PERRY IS THE
LONGEST SERVING GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS, THREE TIMES.
HE SERVED FOR TWO YEARS AS
ENERGY SECRETARY IN TRUMP'S
CABINET.
HOW THIS IMPACTED WHAT HAPPENED
BETWEEN NOVEMBER 4th AND JANUARY
6th IS GOING TO BE KEY TO THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK.
>> AND IT'S INTERESTING ALSO
BECAUSE WE SHOULD NOTE THE THREE
STATES HE WAS CALLING FOR, IT
APPEARED THAT HE PICKED THEM,
AMONG OTHER REASONS, THAT THEY
HAD REPUBLICAN LEGISLATURES.
AND ONE OF THEM, TRUMP WENT ON
TO WIN, NORTH CAROLINA.
HE CITES GEORGIA, NORTH
CAROLINA, PENNSYLVANIA, NORTH
CAROLINA TRUMP WON.
>> BUT NO ONE WAS WAITING.
>> RIGHT.
>> FOR THE VOTERS TO VOTE.
THEY WERE READY TO GO IN, SEND
YOUR OWN ELECTORS.
IGNORE THE VOTERS.
>> AND WE ONLY HAVE HAD EYES
INTO A HANDFUL OF THESE TEXTS
WHEN MARK MEADOWS TURNED OVER
6,000 DOCUMENTS.
>> I THINK THIS IS A VERY KEY
POINT, JAKE.
WE KNOW -- YOU AND I HAVE BOTH
HEARD THAT IN OTHER INSTANCES
WHERE WE'RE SEEING TEXT
MESSAGES, IT'S NOT JUST ONE TEXT
MESSAGE.
WE DON'T KNOW YET, BUT WERE
THERE MULTIPLE TEXT MESSAGES
FROM THIS PHONE, HOW DID MARK
MEADOWS RESPOND TO THAT?
AND REMEMBER AGAIN, MARK MEADOWS
VOLUNTARILY HANDED THIS OVER
WITHOUT ANY CLAIM OF PRIVILEGE
TO THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S ONE OF THE FIRST TEXTS THE
COMMITTEE HAS RELEASED.
THEY CLEARLY SEE IT AS
IMPORTANT.
AND DESPITE THE FACT THAT PERRY
SAYS HE DIDN'T AUTHOR IT, WE DO
KNOW IT CAME FROM HIS PHONE, AND
I'M TOLD THAT EVENTUALLY ALL OF
THESE TEXTS WILL BE IDENTIFIED.
>> IT'S EASY TO DENY SOMETHING
THROUGH A SPOKESPERSON.
IT'S LESS EASY TO DO SO WHEN
YOU'RE UNDER OATH.
WE SHOULD NOTE ABOUT GOVERNOR
PERRY, AND THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO
IN 2015, WHEN HE RAN FOR
PRESIDENT, HE HAS RUN FOR
PRESIDENT TWICE.
IN 2015, RUNNING AGAINST TRUMP,
HE REFERRED TO TRUMPISM AS A
CANCER OF CONSERVATIVISM AND
SAID THAT THAT CANCER WOULD
ULTIMATELY CORRUPT CONSERVATIVE
PRINCIPLES AND, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, THE EVIDENCE IS RIGHT
THERE.
>> I SPOKE TO SOME LONGTIME
REPUBLICANS, PEOPLE WHO KNOW
RICK PERRY VERY WELL ABOUT THIS.
THEY COULD NOT UNDERSTAND WHY HE
WOULD DO THIS, BUT IT DOES SPEAK
TO SOMETHING WE'VE SEEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN WITH TRUMP LOYALISTS
AND THAT IS THIS TEXT IS GOING
AROUND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
END OF STORY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS.
I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE MORE STORIES
ON THIS SUBJECT IN THE FUTURE.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS WITH OUR
PANEL.
S.E. CUPP, LET ME START WITH YOU
BECAUSE BEFORE THE SHOW, YOU
HEARD ME REHEARSING.
WE HAVE THREE INDIVIDUALS ON
BACKGROUND AND A FOURTH OFF THE
RECORD CONFIRMING RICK PERRY'S
PHONE NUMBER FOR US.
THE NUMBER THAT WE GOT FROM A
SOURCE FAMILIAR WITH WHERE THIS
TEXT CAME FROM.
AND THEN WHY DON'T YOU TELL
PEOPLE ABOUT THE CONVERSATION
YOU AND I JUST HAD.
>> WELL, I SAID, YOU KNOW, IF
YOU WANT TO SHARE THE NUMBER, I
HAVE IT AS WELL.
I HAVE THE NUMBER BECAUSE HE
EMAILED ME HIS NUMBER TO TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING UNRELATED.
ACTUALLY ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH.
WE HAD A REALLY INTERESTING,
GOOD, NICE CONVERSATION ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
AND I CORROBORATED THAT WAS THE
NUMBER THAT HE PERSONALLY GAVE
ME.
>> YEAH.
>> SO, LOOK, I LIKE RICK PERRY
PERSONALLY, BUT I THINK THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER IT'S HIS
NUMBER IS PROBABLY THE WRONG
ONE.
WHETHER SOMEBODY GOT A HOLD OF
HIS PHONE, I GUESS IS A
POSSIBILITY, BUT THAT IS RICK
PERRY'S PHONE NUMBER, THE ONE HE
GIVES OUT.
>> WHAT'S ODD ABOUT THAT ALSO
IS, OBVIOUSLY, THEY WON'T OFFER
AN EXPLANATION.
THEY JUST DENY IT.
I DIDN'T WRITE THAT.
>> WELL, IT CAME FROM YOUR
PHONE.
WE'VE NOW CONFIRMED THE PHONE
NUMBER ON TWO DIFFERENT
DATABASES AND FROM FIVE PEOPLE
WHO KNOW YOU.
DANIELA, WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
THIS WITH JAMIE, BUT THIS IS THE
SAME RICK PERRY WHO SAID THIS
SIX YEARS AGO.
>> LET NO ONE BE MISTAKEN,
DONALD TRUMP'S CANDIDACY IS A
CANCER ON CONSERVATISM AND IT
MUST BE CLEARLY DIAGNOSED,
EXCISED AND DISCARDED.
IT CANNOT BE PACIFIED OR
IGNORED.
FOR IT WILL DESTROY A SET OF
PRINCIPLES.
>> IT WILL DESTROY A SET OF
THAT'S INTERESTING.
>> YEAH, WHO KNEW RICK PERRY WAS
GOING TO END UP BEING QUITE THE
SOOTHESAYER.
IT JUST SHOWS AGAIN HOW DEEP THE
ROT OF TRUMPISM HAS GONE WITHIN
THE PARTY.
LOOK, I DON'T AGREE WITH RICK
PERRY ON PROBABLY PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING, BUT GIVEN LIKE WHAT HE
SAID DURING THE 2015 ELECTION, I
NEVER WOULD HAVE GUESSED HE
WOULD HAVE BECOME A PERSON WHO
WOULD TEXT MARK MEADOWS THE DAY
AFTER THE ELECTION BEFORE VOTES
WERE COUNTED TRYING TO SUBVERT
THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY, REALLY DISTURBING
AND IT JUST GOES TO, AGAIN, HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO GET MARK
MEADOWS UNDER OATH AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AFTER HE
RECEIVED THOSE TEXT MESSAGES.
>> S.E., THIS IS A FORMER
GOVERNOR AND CABINET SECRETARY
GENERALLY WELL REGARDED.
AND THIS WEEK WE LEARNED SITTING
LAWMAKERS, JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS, FORMER DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS, SO MANY OF
THEM IN ON THIS ATTEMPT TO UNDO
THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE CAN'T JUST DISMISS THIS AS
FRINGE.
JUST SOME HAIR BRAIN SCHEME
AMONG A COUPLE BAD APPLES.
HOW IS YOUR OWN THINKING SHIFTED
THIS WEEK FROM WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED?
>> WELL, IT WAS A MASSIVE
ATTEMPT AT SCAMMING, RIGGING,
MEDDLING IN AN ELECTION.
ALL THE THINGS DONALD TRUMP HAS
ACCUSED OTHER PEOPLE OF DOING.
ALL THESE PEOPLE WERE INTERESTED
IN DOING.
LOOK, DEMOCRACY WAS AT WORK
WHILE THEY WERE SUGGESTING THIS.
DEMOCRACY WAS DOING ITS JOB.
THE WHEELS OF DEMOCRACY WERE
TURNING BECAUSE THE DEMOCRACY IS
THE COUNTING PART.
THE COUNTING PART OF THE VOTES,
RIGHT?
YOU COUNT THE VOTES.
THAT'S HOW YOU KNOW HOW -- WHO
WON AND WHO VOTED FOR WHOM.
BEFORE THE VOTES WERE COUNTED,
WHILE DEMOCRACY WAS WORKING, ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE WERE SUGGESTING
A SCAM, A WAY TO SCAM AND THWART
DEMOCRACY.
THAT IS PERPETRATING A MASSIVE
FRAUD ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE ANYONE
DEFENDING THIS.
AND I AM N